are you ready to hop back into the world
of mafia this time you'll be going back
to the revolutionary new orleans of 1968
and you won't have to wait long to do it
mafia three hits ps4 xbox one and pc on
october seven pre-ordering mafia three
gets you the family kickback bonus which
includes some exclusive vehicles and
weapons and you have a few options if
you're looking to put your money down
early the $80 limited edition includes
the game and season pass the $150
collector's edition includes the same
season pass plus a vinyl soundtrack art
book art prints and some unannounced
items any of those sound good to you
mafia 3 comes from developer hangar 13
and director Hayden Blackman a man who's
worked on many Star Wars games the third
mafia game will highlight the racial
tension of the deep south during the
late 60s through the eyes of a Vietnam
War vet that's certainly a heavy set up
so keep your eye on gamespot for more
info and for all the open world crime
games you could want you're ready in the
right place
Oh